Why can lipidema have delayed onset?
So the question really need to ask is what is causing the lipidema?
So lipidema just means there's a block in the lip vessel and there's adema, delt
stream, or back stream from where the blockage is.
That's what lipidema is.
So we got to look at cause.
So if the delayed onset you're speaking of as I had lip nodes removed, and then I had
no problems.
And now I have lipidema in my arm, and I have, let's say, lip nodes in my left axillary
area removed.
I had no issues.
And now a year later, I have swelling in my left arm.
How could that's delayed?
Well, it's because if you had some of the lip nodes, some of the vessels removed, what
drains that arm, and you don't have any extra swelling in that arm, you might not notice
anything, but then you get a bug bite or something like that in that arm.
That's going to cause it in flammatory response.
Now, there's not enough lip drainage in that arm that you're exceeding the inflammation in
the arm, and you're exceeding the ability for that to drain.
So you're going to have to work on it.
You're going to have to do some massage, you're going to have to do some cold packs, you're
going to have to look and see what could be a cause of the increased inflammation, what's
or the adema, another word for it, and see, okay, if you kind of go, well, I know what the
lip blockages from, it's from the removal of the lip nodes, okay, well, we got that figured
out, no, what's the cause of the increased inflammation?
Can't just be the heat, you know, outside working in the garden, and you know, that's going
to be a source of inflammation right there.
So find the source of inflammation, and then work on some of the other techniques of getting